China's Aviation Authority ordered all
Chinese airlines to stop flying Boeing
737 max eight Jets after the crash which
killed eight Chinese citizens regulators
pointed to last year's Lian air crash
and said they have zero tolerance for
safety hazards Indonesia and Cayman
Airlines in the Caribbean have also
grounded their max eight planes but the
Federal Aviation Administration has not
taken any action with US airlines Kris
Van Cleave is at Washington's Reagan
National Airport with the questions that
could become a huge problem for Boeing
Chris good morning good morning
American Southwest and United all fly a
version of the 737 max more than 60 of
them are in service here in the US and
the airlines are sticking with the
airplane for now it is too early to know
what happened in Sunday's crash but it
is raising questions again about the
safety of the 737 max Ethiopian Airlines
flight 302 is the second deadly crash
involving the Boeing 737 max in less
than five months in October a lion air
Boeing 737 max eight plunged into the
Java Sea off the coast of Indonesia
killing all 189 people on board while
both incidents are still under
investigation there are already apparent
similarities the pilots of both 737 max
jets reported technical difficulties the
two planes appeared to struggle to gain
altitude before making a steep nosedive
in crashing less than 15 minutes after
takeoff
a preliminary report of the lion air
crash indicates the pilots of that
flight fought to control the plane
because of an automatic safety system
malfunction following the lion air crash
Boeing issued an advisory to 737 max
pilots detailing existing procedures
that can be used to recover from an
abrupt nosedive Steven Wallace is the
former head of Accident Investigation at
the FAA I would not be reluctant to get
on a 737 max but I assure you the
manufacturer is terribly terribly
concerned about this roughly 350 737 max
jets are in service around the world and
Boeing has orders pending for nearly
5,000 the 737 max that crashed Sunday
was delivered to Ethiopian Airlines in
mid-november the airline is one of
because leading carriers most part
airlines that are flying modern Western
equipment and taking the training that
goes with them I have a far superior
safety records Boeing in the National
Transportation Safety Board are sending
teams to Africa to assist with the crash
investigation Norah Chris do we know how
many of these planes are in operation
here within the US there are about 60
currently in use by Southwest American
and United Southwest is the largest
flier of the max currently and then we
talked with Southwest this morning
they're planning to keep them in the air
Nora all right Chris thank you